good morning Hank it's Tuesday also
known as the reckoning of the beard so
Hank almost 5000 people voted about my
beard and the preliminary vote is that I
should keep it but one thing that I
failed to mention in my original video
is that the Yeti always has ten thousand
votes so Sara what's it going to be keep
the beard or shave the beard I can't
decide I have a compromise proposal for
you I said that what if I keep half of
it and done I think I realize you don't
have time lapse at that but it took like
45 minutes plus I cut myself six times
Hank as you know our Father is a
wonderful person but he never taught me
how to shave because when I left for
boarding school even though I was in
tenth grade I didn't need to shave in
fact the person who taught me how to
shave was my tenth grade girlfriend Fran
because I had like one of those Sony my
first mustache things going on and one
day she just took me into my dorm room
bathroom and she was like we are getting
rid of that mustache oh right but so
anyway I was gonna make a video about
something other than facial hair Hank I
don't know if you've noticed this but
I'm about 20% more than I used to be and
I don't mean 20% more awesome I mean 20%
more I know this because a few days ago
Sara and I got a Wii Fit and when you
set up your me on the Wii Fit it
calculates your body mass index or your
BMI and when they calculated my BMI the
game made a sound like oh and then my
knee hung his head in shame as the
program made him portly and Hank I can't
help but notice when I go back and look
at your old videos that you are a little
bit I don't know what what's the word
for it well there's just a little bit
more of you in the middle for the
Catherine to love it's like these days
your body is a little bit better
designed for hula-hooping there used to
be
now obviously Hank you're in better
shape than I am I'm not saying that
you'd have a portly me but nonetheless I
am today announcing the vlogbrothers
2009 fitness challenge two months from
today we will have a contest in three
parts
part one who can run three miles faster
part two who can do more consecutive
push-ups I'm tempted to just forfeit
that category right now and focus on the
other two but I'm gonna try part
three who can get closer to their ideal
BMI I know that BMI is like unscientific
and not that important but whatever
that's what we're gonna do and Hank
because I am confident that I am going
to win I propose that the loser shall be
punished by nerdfighteria Hank I'm so
serious about this that I have hired a
personal trainer a semi-professional
strong man named Donovan in our first
session I said I thought I was gonna
puke and he said that's okay go ahead
all right Hank I got to go work out but
I'll see you singing tomorrow PS
obviously in the end Hank I decided to
abandon the half-shaved look but I
wanted to share with you a few of my
favorite chance that nerdfighters came
up with in the great beard debate of
2009 on the pro beard side there was
hey-ho hey-ho on to John's face hairs
gotta grow and my favorite from the anti
beard side was one puff is enough one
puff is enough but ultimately Hank the
chant that I found most convincing was
John Green won't get no play until its
beard shaving day